[Musique]
imaginez vous puissiez visiter
virtuellement la ville de québec telle
qu'elle était il ya deux cents ans se
serait fascinant et ça pourrait se faire
plus vite que vous le pensez avec la
production d'une version numérique en 3d
d'une maquette détaillée réalisée à
l'époque
c'est une ville de cartons de bois et de
papier avec ses rues ses maisons ses
canons son cimetière et ses rideaux
pendaient aux fenêtres on y entend
presque la ville
l'avis de québec en 1806
on est aujourd'hui devant un objet qui
étaient conçus et 200 ans le fait
d'avoir une maquette de cette envergure
heureux en trois dimensions ça nous
amène dans un autre monde qui en un mois
je goûte plonge dans ses pieds cubes est
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vue avec sa
cathédrale son marché public son
séminaire ces jardins intérieurs et le
château saint-louis qui trouvent sur le
site actuel du château frontenac
c'est le plan relief de québec le seul
du genre et de l'époque à subsister au
pays et aujourd'hui on se prépare à lui
redonner vie
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est une journée
importante parce que depuis que j'ai
fait mes études que la première fois que
j'ai vu cette maquette là j'avais un peu
le rêve de produire la clown numérique
puis aujourd'hui le fait d'être présente
c'est comme si c'était un aboutissement
d'un rêve vieux de 25 ans
[Musique]
le clown numérique est destiné à parcs
canada à qui appartient la maquette
tellement de gens qui la voient en ce
moment la seule façon de l'observer et
de le faire depuis l'extérieur de la
cage de verre où elle est exposée
rares sont ceux qui ont le privilège d'y
entrer c'est pour me rendre plus
accessible et tirer profit des
informations techniques qu'elles
recèlent qu'on veut produire un clown
numérique ouais la maquette va sortir de
sa cage de verre
aujourd'hui le plan relief s'expose
comme une oeuvre d'art mais à l'origine
sa fonction est d'abord militaire
dans le contexte du début du 19e siècle
de nouvelles menaces planent sur québec
on craint les assauts des américains à
la suite de la guerre d'indépendance
tout comme des soulèvements populaires
dans la ville
zizou québec compte déjà des ouvrages
défensifs mais certains sont manquants
du côté des plaines d'abraham et
d'autres sont temporaires comme la
citadelle d'où l'importance de
convaincre l'angleterre du soutenions
des nouveaux plans de défense élaboré
par le commandant des ingénieurs royaux
à québec
les plans reliefs c'est un peu dans le
google earth de l'époque il faut savoir
que ça s'adresse aux donneurs d'ordres à
ceux qui vont financer les travaux et
donc c'était quand même très difficile
d'imaginer pourquoi tel ou tel ouvrage
avancer tel ou tel ouvrage de défense
est nécessaire quand on n'est pas sur le
terme quand on ne comprend pas la
topographie exacte des lieux
et québec compte son lot de pente de cap
et de plaine
mais guy bernier est archéologue
spécialisée dans les ouvrages militaires
une spécialiste des fortifications
québec en maquette là c'est très facile
de percevoir où sont les auteurs où sont
les belles soeurs ou est-ce qu'on peut
s'installer en position de commandement
quels ouvrages sont nécessaires pour se
mettre à l'abri de l'ennemi pendant deux
ans 2008 106 et 1808 l'arpenteur royal
jean baptiste du berger et l'ingénieur
militaire jones by s'attelle à la
réalisation du plan relief de québec
la maquette est construite à l'échelle
de 1 300e la topographie et la position
des ouvrages défensifs doivent être
rigoureusement exacte aujourd'hui enfin
voilà l'avion pis dans trois semaines en
un mot on a un modèle 3d existants alors
qu'ils allaient pas compte des mesures
et on devait représenter qu'on devait se
déplacer dans la ville pour aller pour
défendre les constantes pour aller
mesure il comparé les bâtiments les uns
par rapport aux autres pour les autres
les replacer à l'échelle
c'est avec des outils modernes qu'on va
aujourd'hui à tenter le plan relief
le lidar balaie la pièce sur 360 degrés
à partir de différents points de vue
autour de la maquette
les techniques de photogrammétrie et de
lasers g étrillant français webcam 3d
donc de balayage laser 3d les passages
multiples du laser permettent de créer
un nuage de milliards de coordonner dans
les trois axes x y et z comme relevés
d'arpentage
en parallèle bertrand prend une série de
photos surtout les hommes imaginables
donc l'enjeu est de prendre des milliers
de photos de prendre des milliards de
coordonner 3d les fusionner ensemble
pour réussir à faire leurs clones
numériques précis réaliste à l'échelle
de l'ensemble de la maca
vous
c'est qu'ici j'ai quand même vu en plein
de chacune des stations 3d de
numérisation qui a été fait qui après ça
je peux rentrer dans chacune de ces
stations le pour voir l'image a été
prise on oublie un pu mais avoir accès
encore aujourd'hui à cette maquette t-il
du miracle ou presque
elle a survécu à tous
en 1810 elle plie bagage on leur valent
dans 18 15 quel fils en angleterre là
bas on la remonte pour l'étudier ont
exposé mais tout l'espace on ampute de
moitié il perd une partie des plaines
d'abraham après une tournée de saintes
en angleterre on la vend bac elle rentre
au canada en 1908 mal en point on la
restaure elle passe 80 ans à ottawa puis
en 1981 elle revient québec sa terre
natale et ce qui est assez incroyable
parce qu'elle est elle est là depuis
bout presque 200 ans alors que
normalement bon elles sont faites et
puis une fois qu'elles ont rempli leurs
fonctions on sent des faits
dans ce que si au contraire elle renaît
c'est à trois-rivières china is khan que
le plan relief de québec entame sa
nouvelle vie cette deuxième vie
numérique celle là
et la magie opère c'est comme si on
faisait voler un drone au dessus de
québec il y a deux cents ans
[Musique]
ici on a la petite porte saint-jean qui
était un humain beaucoup plus fermé à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui
ça donne un peu l'impression de
quelqu'un qui a ouvert sur place c'est
le fun parce que ce n'est point de vue
qu'on peut pas vraiment voire lotis dans
la maquette canton et l'autre de l'autre
courtenay vite
s'ajoute aussi avec le modèle numérique
la possibilité de mesurer sur le champ
et virtuellement des distances où le
volume des bâtiments puis de les
comparer à d'autres sources
documentaires
las pour les chercheurs qui le
distance
pour les archéologues qui ont accès aux
plans au code aux élévations
au tous ses autres outils de
représentation du territoire évidemment
c'est une manière de comparer de valider
de voir comment les choses étaient dans
ce moment c'est comme une photographie
de l'époque ce sauf que un plan 2d les
plans des ingénieurs mutants son
entreprise donc on a quand même un très
bon aperçu de ce que sera la leur sauf
que c'est quand même difficile même pour
un archéologue de bien comprendre les
auteurs on les voit ils sont représentés
en 2d mais ça ne donne pas du tout la
même perspective quand on peut le voir
en 3d
en 2017 on a entamé des travaux de
réfection des fortifications les
ouvrages sont dégagées avec grand soin
au préalable les archéologues revoit
entre autres les élévations du sol et
les compare aux plants de différentes
époques une élévation plus grand vous
laisserait supposer par exemple qu'il ya
eu des remblais et que certains vestiges
pourrait se cacher sous les premières
couches du sol
chaque fois qu'on a un projet qui tous
les fortifications de québec on se
retourne vers la maquette du berger
parce que à chaque fois qu'on a une
problématique précise on la regarde sous
un autre angle
mais le choix des angles de vue illimité
avec la maquette originale on ne peut
pas glisser au dessus d'elle prendre
position au centre pour évaluer
différentes perspectives avec le clown
numérique si sans limite je peux mettre
exactement je veux avoir à vol d'oiseau
c'est inestimable ça permet de
comprendre les choses de façon
complètement différente
on va être capable d'aller tous les
arrondis donc plus comme ça comme ça on
va aller dans un haut niveau de détails
qu'on comprend pas attendre et si l on
devait passer tout il aurait en plus
qu'on peut le faire au bureau alors qui
on peut se déplacer chaque fois la
possibilité de se positionner où l'on
veut dans la maquette virtuelle donne
aussi la chance d'adopter des points de
vue similaires certaines illustrations
de la même époque
ici par exemple pour le point de vue
sinon à celui de james coburn au début
du 19e siècle avec l'ancien palais de
justice de québec donc ce qu'il faut
c'est que on peut faire un comparatif
finalement d'iconographie anciennes puis
la maquette le plan deniev
avec l'acquisition de toutes ces données
sous forme numérique le plan relief
retrouve sa pertinence dans le monde
moderne
la possibilité par exemple j'ai
superposé les plans actuels de la ville
de québec sur la ville du début du 19e
siècle alors le mode animé rey l'a fait
sortir de sa cage à la ramène sur sa
trajectoire d'une petite techniques de
représentation du territoire et donc ça
crée un lien entre les arpenteurs les
ingénieurs de l'époque et les arpenteurs
du magicien ingénieurs de notre époque
pour parcs canada la création du clown
numérique ouvre toutes les portes dont
la possibilité d'exploiter la réalité
virtuelle pour des visites guidées les
les histoires nous raconte une histoire
alors que là elle se déroule devant nous
on voit pas les personnages mais revoit
leur envoie le portrait on voit le
tableau dans lequel ils évoluent est en
fait au début du 19e siècle
pour pouvoir se promener à travers
québec au début du 19e siècle sépare des
traversiers nouveau laborde saint-jean
déambuler dans les rues de la capitale
arpenter une terrine ou vers douvres âge
défensif s'est aussi d'une certaine
façon repartir ré conquête de québec
[Musique]